one of the reasons why i chose stanford
was that
i knew i was going to be getting a jd
mba i was going to be a dual degree
student and i wanted to come to a
university that was
supportive of that and stanford really
stood out for me
as somewhere where that was possible and
easy you know it's everything from
the fact that the schools are physically
proximate so you can get from one school
to another
in between classes to the fact that the
faculty and the deans really do
emphasize
dual degrees and just multi-disciplinary
study
um so that it's not weird that i'm a
joint degree student it's cool and
people you know understand the value in
that
i feel like it's really been supported
and the gsb especially
emphasizes students ability to take
classes across the street and
experience more than just the gsb has to
offer
you know i think you sort of have the
best of both worlds at stanford with a
small
intimate school but an amazing
university
that it lives in so you can really
experience all that
a world-class university has to offer
while still feeling like you're part of
a
small school family